Salut la team mentalo !
Le nouvel IPhone est sorti. C'est le septième du nom.
Etanche, nouveau bouton home, deux fois plus de rapidité et de puissance et avec le système d'exploitation le plus avancé de...
On ne la pas déjà entendu ça ?
Si si, à chaque fois !
La sorti du nouvel IPhone ça m'a donné envie de creuser pour voir sur quel levier se base Apple pour nous donner envie d'aller dans le futur.
Dans leur futur à eux, tel qu'ils l'ont pensé, imaginé.
Et comme vous pouvez le constater, mon présent c'est de faire cette vidéo dans les loges, puisque je suis en spectacle dans quelques heures à la Garenne-Colombes.
Alors comme on regarde un petit peu de quelle manière s'y prend Apple, on peut dire que oui, chez Apple, ils sont un petit peu mentalistes.
Vous ne connaissez surement pas le "Genius Training". Ca c'est un livre, qu'on donne à tous les nouveaux vendeurs de chez Apple qui vont travailler dans les Apple stores.
Les Apple stores physiques, parce qu'il n'y a pas de petits vendeurs dans l'application Apple store !
Dans ce bouquin, on trouve tous les chapitres de base sur le matériel, etc, toutes les caractéristiques techniques.
Mais on trouve aussi des chapitres très étonnant... Comme "Le pouvoir de l'empathie" !
Qui décrit précisément comment mettre en confiance un acheteur et l'emmener jusqu'à conclure une vente tout en lui laissant le sentiment que c'est lui qui a prit la décision de l'acheter.
Pas bête la pomme !
Donc en cherchant et en procédant, j'en suis arrivé à la conclusion que leurs vendeur sont réellement des comédiens.
Ils leurs demande en tout cas d'être comédien. Ils ont un rôle à jouer. Ils ont même une liste de mots interdit, qui n'ont pas le droit de prononcer !
Ou encore des réactions préprogrammées en fonction de certaines situations.
Leur règle d'or c'est: Aborder, interroger, présenter, écouter, et terminer.
En anglais ça fait : APPLE. Avec les initiales.
Et tout passe par l'identification.
Par exemple si un client trouve un Mac trop cher, alors le vendeur va se positionner comme étant un ancien client ayant accepté cela.
Pourquoi ? Pour que l'acheteur s'identifie dans le vendeur, et du coup qu'il suive le même raisonnement... et qu'il achète !
Et qu'il accepte. Et qu'il achète surtout !
Exemple très concret, le client dit: "Non mais quand même... le Mac Book c'est beaucoup trop cher !"
Le vendeur devra répondre quelque chose du style: "Oui je comprends tout à fait que vous pensiez cela, moi aussi je trouvais que c'était trop cher pour un ordinateur,
et puis j'ai trouvé le prix complètement justifié quand j'ai vu toutes les capacités qu'il avait et quels logiciels étaient installés en native dès le départ."
Alors ça c'est vrai, c'est en boutique, mais même en virtuel, c'est-à-dire sur Internet et dans la communication globale, ils s'appuient sur pleins de leviers psychologiques qui sont hyper ciselés.
Lorsqu'en 2007, Steeve Jobs présente le premier IPhone, ils rendent l'évènement tellement gros, ça fait tellement de bruit dans le monde entier,
que le CES qui était à Las Vegas cette année là, est passée pour une fete campagnarde.
Personne n'en parlait.
La technique est très très simple, donner très peu d'informations et toujours au compte goutte.
En faisant ça comme ça, à chaque fois qu'ils donnent une petite info, aussi petite soit elle, tout le monde s'en empare.
Tous les spécialistes sen parlent, tous les blogs font un article dessus, toute la rumeur enfle.
Ils jouent donc avec deux essentiels: créer le manque et le désir, et susciter la curiosité en permanence.
Et quand t'étudies leurs techniques de communications, c'est hyper intéressant parce qu'ils se sont attaqués à deux leviers psychologiques très simples.
Et ils ne les ont pas complexifiés, au contraire, ils sont allés à la base pour créer se gros manque en permanence.
Après bien sur, ils ont utilisé d'autres techniques, mais qui sont plus des techniques commerciales, pour pourvoir favoriser tout ça dans un espèce de microcosme.
Par exemple ils rendent les clients captifs, en faisant tout fonctionner par l'ITunes et en faisant en sorte que tout l'hardware fonctionne bien l'un avec l'autre.
Depuis 2008 en créant l'Apple store ils ont quand même une la bonne idée de faire travailler tous les créatifs de la planète pour eux gratos.
Parce que ce sont eux les programmateurs qui sortent les applis que nous on aime.
Et Apple se prend généreusement 30% de commission sur toutes les applis qui sont vendues.
Et au final, chez la pomme ils ont réussi à créer un monde, un univers, une espèce de bande où on veut tous faire partis.
J'ai remarqué quelque chose et c'est ça aussi qui m'a motivé à faire cette vidéo.
Dans la vie quotidienne, personne ne dit la marque de ses objets.
"J'allume mon ordi, je cherche où est mon téléphone, je recharge ma tablette."
Mais quand tu as un produit Apple, c'est différent ! T'allumes ton Mac, tu cherches où est-ce que tu as mis ton IPhone, ou alors tu recharges ton Ipad.
Et ça c'est une preuve qui ne ment pas, comme quoi ils ont réussi leur technique d'identification.
Alors cette vidéo, c'est pas une critique du tout d'Apple en soi.
Parce que moi j'adore cette marque. J'ai même beaucoup trop de produits Apple chez moi en permanence.
J'aime bien renouveler ça.
Ils ont pour eux d'être visionnaires, et ils savent se rendre sexy.
Contrairement à d'autres marquent qui parfois ont les mêmes prétentions en logiciels, ou en hardware ou en software.
Mais on a moins envie d'aller chez eux...
Et la sortie de l'IPhone 7 était une bonne occasion de creuser un petit peu sur les techniques qu'ils avaient employées chez Apple depuis le départ et de vous en parler.
Merci d'avoir regarder cette vidéo jusqu'au bout.
Si vous êtes encore là au moment où je parle, vous pouvez mettre un pouce en l'air. Si vous voulez me voir ailleurs que dans une loge, vous avez toutes les dates de spectacles sur le site Internet, il y a le lien dans le descriptif.
Il y a toujours tout ce que tu cherches dans le descriptif. A chaque fois !
Et bien sur abonnez vous avant partir, puisque le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an, donc rendez-vous demain à 11H.
Ciao !
[musique]